ich arbeite mit armut prostituierten die
machen den großteil in der prostitution
aus und das findet fast zu 100 prozent
statt missbrauch der freier die frauen
wenn man zwangsprostitution aus der welt
schaffen will dann muss man armut
beseitigen das einzel heute auf morgen
aber nun hast du da steckt viel mehr
dahinter
wenn es um prostitution geht dann sind
sehr viele menschen direkt bei
zwangsprostitution bei menschenhandel
und bei ausbeutung dass das alles ein
ende haben muss das ist natürlich klar
die frage ist nur auf 16 kaufverbot die
richtige lösung dafür ist meine heutigen
gäste die sind sich da auf gar keinen
fall einig die einen sagen sex gegen
geld kann so gut wie nie freiwillig sein
und gehört deswegen verboten
die anderen sagen ein verbot führt zu
noch mehr kriminalität und zu weniger
selbstbestimmung es wird definitiv keine
einfache diskussion heute ich freue mich
aber sehr darauf und stelle wie immer
die erste frage von 13 fragen an euch
sollte sex gegen geld erlaubt sein
schreibt mir in die kommentare wir
machen jetzt erstmal eine
positionierungs runde weil wir wissen ja
noch gar nicht auf welcher seite des
feldes ihr steht deswegen habe ich jetzt
drei fragen für euch und wenn ihr meinen
fragen zustimmt dann geht er jetzt
gleich ein schritt ins gelbe kästchen
wenn ihr meine fragen nicht zustimmt
dann geht er einen schritt ins grüne
kästchen genau dann fange ich an
zweite frage von 13 fragen verschlimmert
ein sex kaufverbot die situation aller
sex arbeitenden ja oder nein
in der seit jahren geld in der 69 dann
grün meiner meinung nach brauchen wir
das exportverbot denn die freiwillige
selbstbestimmte prostitution ist die
absolute ausnahme
ich bin ganz klar gegen 16 kaufverbot
ich war selber prostituierte über drei
jahre und fünf jahre habe ich in der
rote branche gearbeitet hab gut so wie
schlecht mitbekommen und bin der meinung
dass man sich erst mal alle facetten von
diesen beruf anschauen sollte in
berührung ist ein grundbedürfnis sollte
jeder oder jede selbst entscheiden
dürfen ob er oder sie sex gegen geld
anbieten oder in anspruch nehmen darf ja
oder nein
ein sex-verbot in der hinsicht finde ich
moralisch und paternalistisch und ich
finde dass der staat sich da nicht
einzumischen hat
ich denke eine gesellschaft kann niemals
vollkommen gleichberechtigt sein solange
es normal ist frauenkörper kaufen zu
können
deswegen denke ich dass das ex
kaufverbot ein feministischer akt ist um
patriarchale macht strukturen
aufzubrechen
das waren so halbe schritte okay ein sex
verbot wäre ein schlag ins gesicht aller
selbstbestimmten freiwilligen sex
arbeitenden ja oder nein
ein sex verbot wäre kein schlag ins
gesicht aller freiwillige und
selbstbestimmten sexarbeiterinnen weil
es davon ganz ganz wenigen uhr gibt und
das recht dieser ganz ganz wenigen
rechtfertigt nicht das unfassbare leid
der vielen vielen anderen fans ex
kaufverbot wäre insofern ein schlag ins
gesicht aller sechs arbeitenden da es am
ende des tages dann doch wieder zu einer
tabuisierung von sexarbeit führt und vor
allem auch auf die sexualität der frau
ab zielt diese zu kontrollieren war
immer schon eine aufgabe und ein wunsch
des patriarchats und ich bin
grundsätzlich dagegen
damit sind eure position klar ich will
natürlich interessieren auf welcher
seite des feldes findet ihr stehen
schreibt es mir in die kommentare
und damit kommen wir zur nächsten runde
das ist eine runde der ich schon mal ein
bisschen versuchen eure position die
sich jetzt so herauskristallisiert haben
zu hinterfragen und mal gucken ob mir
das gelingt
ich fange mit euch an fünfte frage von
13 fragen 16 kaufverbot das solle jahr
zwangsprostitution verhindern indem die
freier bestraft werden also die kunden
und kundinnen der sexarbeiterin und die
sexarbeiterinnen selbst werten
entkriminalisiert wisst ihr zugestehen
dass menschen den er zwangsprostitution
landen dann nicht einig von diesem
gesetz profitieren würden
was sagt ihr wenn er zustimmt dann könnt
ihr jetzt einen schritt auf mich
zukommen
und wenn ich dann bleibt ihr stehen oder
geht einen schritt zurück du hast dich
so ein bisschen bewegt war es ein
schritt oder ok warum weil ich denke für
die seite gezwungen wird ist es auf
jeden fall vielleicht ein guter
schritten aber es gibt ja noch mehr
aspekte die wir in betracht ziehen
müssen dass es nicht nur diese frauen
sind sondern das ist ein breites
spektrum von menschen ist die da
betroffen sind und dass nur diese lösung
den hilft aber wiederum anderen wiederum
schadet so sieht ihr wollt das glaube
ich erst mal ganz schritt nach
zurückgehen ja ich denke dass es
niemandem hilft also das was heute schon
im dunkel bereich stattfindet das wird
durch einen sex kaufverbot nicht ins
licht gedrängt oder mehr aufgedeckt also
das ist ein trugschluss
ihr merkt die seite ist überwiegend sehr
stark gegen das text kaufverbot jetzt
bin ich bei euch da zwangsprostitution
und menschenhandel ja bereits verboten
ist wird mit dem sex kaufverbot auch die
freiwillige und selbstbestimmte
sexarbeit verboten müssen wir aufhören
alle sexarbeiterinnen zu opfern zu
stigmatisieren was sagt ihr kommt er
einen schritt auf mich zu
josefine stimmt mir so ein bisschen
sowieso weil ich finde man geht von
dieser großen gruppe aus die gezwungen
wird und unser elend und armut arbeitet
aber man darf eben nicht die minderheit
vergessen die eben aus freiwilligkeit in
der prostitution ist linie du siehst du
nicht so nee ich sehe es nicht zur welt
die weil wir nicht unterstellen können
dass zwangsprostitution und
menschenhandel ja heute schon verboten
sind und deshalb ein sex-verbot keinen
sinn macht ich fordere ja auch kein
sechs kaufverbot alleine
ich fordere ein sex-verbot nach
nordische modell das heißt die vordere
auch die in kriminalisierung der frauen
die bestrafung der freiherr
ausstiegshilfen und breite aufklärung in
der gesellschaft das ist meine forderung
in 6 k verbot alleine fordere ich nicht
und den frauen derzeit in der
prostitution wird nicht geholfen die
kriegen kaum ausstiegshilfen weil halt
vom staat gesagt wird naja es ist halt
eine arbeit wie jede andere auch warum
sollen wir den frauen dann helfen also
bist du um auf eine frage noch mal
zurückzukommen nicht der meinung dass
wir alle sechs arbeiten denn dann auf
eine art und weise stigmatisieren und zu
opfern machen
auch die die sich freiwillig dafür
entscheiden durch dieses sechs
kaufverbot oder durch das nordische
modell
naja das nordische modell erkennt
prostitution als gewalt gegen frauen an
und dafür ist es unerheblich ob jemand
jetzt sagt er macht das freiwillig oder
nicht
genauso wie zum beispiel die vereinten
nationen die haben das schon 1949
festgestellt und in der konvention
festgehalten dass prostitution gegen die
menschenwürde verstößt und es ist
unerheblich ist ob jemand jetzt sagt er
macht das freiwillig oder nicht also
dass prostitution für dich immer gleich
gewalt prostitution ist für mich gewalt
damit sind eure position klar und wir
gehen in die nächste runde
das ist eine persönliche runde in der
ich jede von euch einmal ansprechen
werde
und einmal vor allem nach eurem
persönlichen motivation oder auch
geschichte fragen werde warum ihr auf
dem feld dort steht wo er gerade steht
ich möchte aber erstmal von euch wissen
welche vorurteile habt ihr dann
gegenüber sexarbeiterinnen okay dann
kommen wir zur siebten frage von 13
fragen oder inter
du hast mit 19 angefangen sex gegen geld
anzubieten warum durch ein loverboy ein
mann der mich manipuliert hat in die
prostitution gebracht hat aber ich
wollte es auch freiwillig ich wollte ein
verrücktes leben ich wollte mich selber
entdecken ich wollte in meinem körper
spüren ich wollte wissen was sexualität
für mich bedeutet was sexualität für
andere menschen bedeutet ein schritt den
ich gegangen bin natürlich mit dem
falschen menschen der mich benutzt und
ausgebeutet hat er auch die möglichkeit
dazu hatte wegen dem system weiß möglich
war mich auszunutzen und auszubeuten
warum hast du dann aufgehört damit warum
ich aufgehört habe ist dass ich
tatsächlich traum und hass erlebt habe
in der post sitzung weil ich meine
eigenen grenzen nicht kannte ich hab nur
zehn männern pro tag geschlafen ich war
zu jung es gab kein mindestalter und ich
hatte zu wenig lebenserfahrung für
diesen beruf und für mein körper war der
ausstieg der schwer
er ist immer noch schwer für mich
tatsächlich weil ich auch in der
öffentlichkeit stehe und ich gar nicht
so recht weiß wo mein weg hingehen soll
wie ich weitermachen soll ich habe
schwierigkeiten dass mich leute ernst
nehmen sie denken ich bin nur die
prostituierte ich krieg doch ähnlich
sind aber was ich wirklich gelernt habe
in meinem leben unter meinem beruf oder
auch die menschenkenntnis die ich
mitgenommen habe die sieht keine bevor
wir zu deiner bewegungen auf dem feld
kommen warum das gerade einen
traumatischen erfahrungen gesprochen
warum bist du denn trotz dieser
erfahrung gegen das sex kauf verbot
würde die das nordische modell nicht
genau dann helfen
ich bin gegen sex kaufverbot weil ich
alle facetten gesehen habe für mich
selber natürlich habe ich nicht die
facette von menschenhandel oder wo
frauen wirklich sehr schlimm leiden
gesehen aber die facette die anderen
drei faktoren die es für mich gibt
einmal die seite warum männer sexuelle
dienstleistung nutzen oder menschen an
sich körperliche dienstleistungen nutzen
ja der nähe ist für mich ein
grundbedürfnis was manche menschen so
nicht bekommen können
egal ob frau der man es gibt so viele
erotische berufe die nicht unbedingt
immer mit penetration zu tun haben und
es wird einfach gesagt
tantra sexuell sexual als assistent sexy
body work das ist alles eins und es
passt für mich nicht weil da steckt noch
viel mehr dahinter und wie man den wenn
man sich das noch nie alles angesehen
hat dann kann man es nicht wirklich
verstehen man muss mehrere lösungen
dafür finden
das war orient us-geschichte ihr könnt
euch jetzt gerne dazu auf dem feld
positionieren du bist schon ein schritt
nach vorne wieder nach hinten gegangen
so fielen ihr könnt auch gerne auf sie
zugehen wenn ihr sitzt ihr zustimmt oder
einen schritt nach indien oder
stehenbleiben
ich bin unentschlossen ist
unentschlossen darf ich eine frage
stellen ja natürlich ich bin vorgegangen
als du gesagt hast dass es damals kein
mindestalter gab wärst du für ein
mindest ein einstiegsalter 21 und
teilweise sogar ein bisschen höher weil
ich der meinung bin dass man die für
sich selber als frau auch
selbstbewusstsein muss und auch seinen
körper seine grenzen kennen und ich
wusste meine grenzen früher nicht ja ich
dachte oh ich weiß alles vom leben aber
das wusste ich nicht
meiner meinung nach hat niemals die frau
die schuld wenn sie nicht die grenzen
setzen konnte und die hat nicht die
aufgabe den freier gegenüber zu sagen
nie hier stoppt bis hierhin und nicht
weiter sondern meiner meinung nach
müssen wir als gesellschafter anders
dran gehen und wir müssen auf diejenigen
gucken die überhaupt grenzen
überschreiten also die frauen sozusagen
da etwas mit den machen ohne und geld
dafür geben und genau wissen wenn sie
das geld nicht geben würden würden die
frauen das ja nicht mit sich machen
lassen
ganz kurz hinter der ersten schritt
zurückgegangen
das ist so ja halben jahr das so nie
jemand schuld ist also dass frauen
niemals schuld sind oder allgemein das
ist für mich so jeder mensch trägt einen
teil dazu bei für mich egal welches
geschlecht
ich finde das findet dann aber alles an
dem sehr privilegierten rahmen statt
also ich arbeite mit armut
prostituierten die machen den großteil
in der prostitution aus die überwiegende
mehrheit wenn du schuld streichen wird
dann im verantwortung aber in dem fall
und das findet fast zu 100 prozent statt
missbrauch der freier die frauen und
missbraucht ihre verletzlichkeit und
ihre
wirtschaftlich soziale lage
missbrauchtes dass sie kein deutsch
sprechen können ihre rechte nicht kennen
sich nicht wehren können also ich finde
schon da muss man beim beim beim man
beim freier ansätzen ganz klar also
diese 100 seiner kokain hinter der
realen grundlage
einen halben schritt davor weil also mit
den männern dass männer das denken
verändern müssen bzw
dass männer frauen benutzen das stimmt
das machen manche viele sogar
ich merke das ja auch wenn ich so mit
männer sex ab dass viele keinen respekt
habe und das was wir eigentlich tun
sollten ist menschen zu zeigen oder auch
männer dass man respekt vor dem mensch
haben soll egal ob frau oder mann aber
respekt ist in der prostitution meiner
meinung gar nicht nach gar nicht möglich
weil im vergleich dazu privaten wie man
hat respekt das ist ja das ist ja kein
zufall dass es in der regel männer sind
die geld hinlegen damit die frau
zustimmt und etwas zu sexuellen
handlungen zustimmt und das ist kein
zufall
über diesen beruf gemacht und ich habe
gelernt ich habe gemerkt ok warum sind
menschen vielleicht respektlos was kann
ich dafür machen das zu verändern also
habe ich meine berufswahl mich selber
verändert ich habe anders mit den gästen
geredet ich habe meine regel festgelegt
ich habe sie als mensch gesehen ich habe
ihnen in die augen geschaut gesagt wer
ich bin von mir erzählt von meiner
persönlichkeit wie ich bin und die
menschen haben mich als mensch
respektiert umgesehen und so konnte ich
auch das denken von meinen kunden
verändern und auch der umgang mit an
einen anderen kollegen wo ich in den
laden gearbeitet habe da kann ich gleich
würde ich gerne darauf reagieren also
ich finde zum beispiel freier foren also
alle menschen die sich mal interessieren
wie freier wirklich denken sollten sich
mal ein freier forum anschauen es gibt
im internet was ich vorhin wo sich
freier darüber austauschen was sie mit
den frauen gemacht haben und wie sie sie
bewerten und allein wenn man sich sowas
mal anschaut sieht man wie herablassen
und wie abwerten freier über diese
frauen denken und die denken nicht heute
war jetzt aber irgendwie nett und total
respektvoll und so na klar und dem
handvoll den konsens gefunden sondern
die schreiben dann ja die brüste naja so
waren schon ein bisschen verbraucht und
soja und sie war hat jetzt nicht so gut
mitgemacht und nein gesagt und woher
heran
hat rom geschickt und so die kommentare
sind widerlich menschenunwürdig und
respektlos ja ich habe das selber
miterlebt ich habe solche kommentare
über mich gelesen ich war verletzt ich
habe geweint
aber was sind das für menschen die sowas
schreiben ja das sind menschen die
sexualisiert sind die nur denken geil
titten kein respekt vor menschen haben
wir kommen gehört zum respekt dass wir
respekt lernen sollten unserer kultur
und den menschen als mensch sehen
auch das fängt schon an den anderen
berufen ja dass wir uns auf augenhöhe
begegnen auch wenn wir verschiedene
meinungen vertreten
das und so ist es auch bei frau und mann
denn aber männer sich mal über frauen
stellen und sagen ob dies sei nichts
wert weil damit ich meinen mag hier
stellen kann dann wird sich da auch
nichts verändern aber gerade durch
prostitution wird sich ja nicht zwar in
einem postulat ja dieses modell dass
männer denken ja nicht einfach so
abteilungen und da muss man natürlich
ansetzen als gesellschaft und durch
unsere gesetze die wir zur prostitution
haben haben wir natürlich eine klare
haltung als gesellschaft sozusagen zur
prostitution und momentan sagen wieder
na ja ist das eine arbeit wie jede
andere und ja gut und das meiste findet
schon irgendwie freiwillig statt und
dann gibt's vielleicht noch ein bisschen
zwangsprostitution und da versuchen wir
vielleicht mal ein bisschen was gegen zu
machen aber sonst läuft ja schon alles
gut und so was ist das für eine
gesellschaft also wir wollen doch eine
gesellschaft haben wo männer und frauen
gleichberechtigt sind
wo und da nun aber anschauen nicht nicht
die wahl nehmen welchen job sie machen
wollen also dieses ewige gerede davon
dass 95 prozent aller prostituierten das
aus zwang tun ja wir leben im
kapitalistischen system also keiner
dieses kamera keiner von diesen
kamerateam würde heute hier sein wenn es
nicht mehr um die miete zu bezahlen und
essen auf den tisch aber es ist ein
unterschied ob manche filmt und
sortieren oder aber immer die der armut
poster kann also jeder mensch arbeitet
weil er irgendwie miete zahlen muss ich
find das zur verfügung stellen möchte
auch etwas dazu sagen diese freier foren
ich glaube dass da halt sehr viel
abwertung stattfindet allerdings hat das
was mit männlichkeit zu tun mit den
männlichkeits bildern die in unserer
gesellschaft herrschen und reproduziert
werden ständig ich bin keine
sexarbeiterin ich bin eine rassismus
kritisch und feministische autorin
guckt euch doch bitte mal drunter
kommentare an in den sozialen netzwerk
ich werde sexistisch und rassistisch
beleidigt ständig ständig was machen wir
dafür was macht das mit mir das ist halt
natürlich gewalt selbstverständlich
allerdings schwindet das stadt während
ich auch keine sexarbeiterin bin also
muss das was damit zu tun haben was wir
als gesellschaft von männlichkeit
verstehen weil das überwiegend männer
sind dem ich auf diese art und weise
angreifen
ich muss auch was dazu sagen du hast die
ganze zeit gesagt es ist halt ein beruf
wie jeder andere
in deutschland herrscht diese
perspektive gar nicht sex arbeiterinnen
müssen sich bei der behörde registrieren
ich muss das nicht als autorin das nennt
man so und also dieser sogenannte hohen
pass beispielsweise was hat ein stigma
es selbstverständlich in einer behörde
hinein zu laufen und zu sagen ich bin
sexarbeiterin während man weist
inwiefern dieser beruf stigmatisiert und
von dämonisiert wird in dieser
gesellschaft das deshalb
selbstverständlich eine situation in der
sie zwangs geachtet werden unabhängig
davon ob sie dazu bereit sind das zu
machen oder nicht also ich denke nicht
dass in dieser gesellschaft diese
perspektive diese blickweise herrscht
das sexarbeit erhalten beruf sei wie
jeder andere
ich würde gegen hindu wissenschaft leben
in der die feier stigmatisiert werden
du wirst auch gerade einen schritt
zurückgegangen deswegen wollte ich dich
gerne fragen ob du denkst dass wir in
deutschland zu liberalen mit
prostitution umgehen nein es gab ja
ziele als wir die prostitution in
deutschland liberalisiert haben das ziel
war die frauen sollen ihr entgelt
einklagen können sie soll nicht
stigmatisiert werden sie sollen
unabhängig sein von zuhältern sie sollen
sich krankenversichern können und das
ergebnis als 20 jahre später ist die
frauen sind immer noch stigmatisiert
warum auch immer ich führe auch keinen
kampf gegen prostituierte frauen ich
führe ein kampf gegen das system
prostitution
sie sind im aller geringsten teil nicht
kann also sind nicht krankenversichert
sind sie immer noch abhängig von
zuhältern ich habe in stuttgart in
paradise prozess verfolgt da saubermann
bordell deutschlands auch da haben die
rockerbanden geherrscht und insofern ist
es auch die frage der zusammensetzung
hier wäre hier natürlich fehlen das sind
schon die die bordellbetreiber die
immobilienbesitzer und was fehlt sind
die x 90 prozent frauen in der
prostitution die aus dem
russland kommen und die sind eben nicht
in der lage mit einem freier auf
augenhöhe etwas auszuhandeln oder nein
zu sagen wenn die nicht machen was von
ihnen verlangt wird
das haben wir auch in paradise prozess
gelernt und wird mit den frauen im wald
gegangen und dann werden die windelweich
geprügelt und es hat nichts mit
selbstbestimmung zu tun und ich würde
gerne mal politik machen in deutschland
nicht für die wenigen selbstbestimmten
frauen in der prostitution sondern für
die mehrzahl der frauen die ist
zwangsweise und nicht freiwillig macht
ich bin ja migranten hier kommuniziere
ich auf meiner zweiten sprache ich
spreche deutsch seit 2009 unterhaltung
kann bestätigen dass sprachbarriere
natürlich ein sehr großes problem ist
vor allem wenn es um grenzen setzen geht
aber meinst du dass man dieses problem
mit dem nordischen modell lösen kann ja
inwiefern also ich glaube einfach dass
historische modell mit denen frau auch
den frauen die hand reicht und uns sagt
willst du also a hat haben die in
schweden im verhältnis zu deutschland
deutlich weniger frauen in der
prostitution in allen handys nordische
modell haben haben sie im verhältnis zur
einwohnerzahl deutlich weniger das
stellen gibt es studien dazu gibt es
studien so es sind weniger das heißt es
ist schon gar nicht interessant die
frauen in länder zu verbringen
die das nordische modell haben
deutschland ist zielend des weltweiten
und europäischen menschenhandels zum
zweck der sexuellen ausbeutung auch dazu
gibt es zahlen von europol die
europäische kommission stellte fest
deutschland ist das mekka für
menschenhändler und damit habe ich ein
problem
alle großen menschenrechtsorganisationen
von amnesty international bis world
health organisation gibt es eine
riesengroße liste die sagen alle dass es
nordische modell in den ländern in denen
es eingeführt wurde nicht zu weniger
position geführt hat und auch nicht zu
weniger menschen handeln sondern
ausschließlich bewirkt hat dass die sexy
rockerin die existieren in uns also in
einem unsichereren kontext agieren
es gibt es gibt keine belege dafür dass
das nordische modell tatsächlich zu
weniger prostitution vielleicht sind die
zahlen gleich gewinnen wenn man
zwangsprostitution aus der welt schaffen
bildung
in armut beseitigen das einzel heute auf
morgen aber nicht hast du da steckt viel
mehr dahinter anderem ja das wäre
tatsächlich auch eine frage gewesen die
ich jetzt an sich gehabt hätte
verschieben wir nicht durch diese
diskussion über das exportverbot über
das nordische modell ein bisschen die
probleme die wir eigentlich haben viele
menschen die in zwangsprostitution
landen landen dort durch diskriminierung
landen dort durch armut sind das nicht
eigentlich die probleme die wir
bekämpfen sollten weil das sind ja auch
die probleme die die besonders am herzen
liegen die du gerade aufgezählt hast na
ja aber ich meine dass 6k verbot kann er
nichts gegen armut
deshalb wäre ich wohl was wir machen
müssen ist natürlich auch in den in den
ländern aus denen die frauen zu uns
kommen
da haben wir auch zu unterstützen und zu
helfen also nicht jetzt irgendwie mit
dem erhobenen zeigefinger sondern wir
müssen es würde schon genügen oft in
afrika wenn wir die länder nicht
ausbeuten würden aber es ist wirklich
ein unterschied dass wir dann sagen naja
dann sollen sie doch froh sein so klingt
sie heraus dass die hier als in der
prostitution arbeiten lassen kein
absolutes ist absolut also ich denke
grundgesetz artikel 1 die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar gilt für alle
menschen gilt für alle frauen und geht
auch für die frauen in der prostitution
und da steht ja nicht die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar kummer es sei
denn man zahlt dafür also dass das hat
auch keiner gesagt aber eben genau wenn
die würde des menschen unantastbar ist
sollte man sich vielleicht eher die
frage stellen warum menschen überhaupt
in der zwangsprostitution landen aber da
muss man sich ja auch mal deutlich
machen ich meine warum gibt es
prostitution prostitution gibt es ja
nicht weil es frauen gibt die in armut
sind sondern es gibt prostitution weiß
männer gibt die bereit sind geld zu
zahlen um sexuelle handlungen mit frauen
durchzuführen ohne die freier würde es
keine prostitution gehen es würde ohne
freier kein menschen handelt neben guten
wurde ohne freier keine keine bordelle
geben also ich finde das auch ein
bisschen schade dass bei diesem thema
immer die frauen diejenigen sind die
sich dann rechtfertigen müssen warum sie
jetzt in der prostitution waren oder
warum seine prostitution sind und ja und
warum sie nicht ausgestiegen sind oder
wie auch immer
ob es jetzt freiwillig machen oder nicht
freiwillig machen für mich ist das total
unerheblich ich finde wir müssen
wegkommen von dem frauen diskutieren
miteinander und die einen sagen ja das
eine und die anderen sagen dass andere
und die männer sind auch noch diejenigen
die freuen sich noch darüber
wenn wir frauen uns irgendwie uneinig
sind und die freier die lachen sich doch
alle ein dass wir noch ihr recht
verteidigen dass männer per geld
sexuellen zugang zu kauffrauen kaufen
können also das ist doch patriarchat
erster klasse wir sprechen hier gar
nicht über die dunklen seiten von diesem
modell die tatsache dass diese sex
arbeit trotzdem weiterhin stattfindet
dass man das mit verboten nicht
verhindern kann sondern einfach in das
es in dunkle ecken verlagert wird wo
mehr rechtsverletzungen mehr gewalt
stattfindet mehr polizeiwillkür mehr
polizeigewalt weniger zugang auf
medizinische versorgung sie sind
unversichert sie erleben gewalt und sie
wissen nicht weile weil die
beratungsangebote auch ausfallen weil
beratungsangebote beispielsweise in
sachen gesundheitliche aufklärung unter
prostitutions befürwortung auch
verurteilt werden kann dass sie auch gar
keinen zugang zu informationen haben und
wir wissen auch auf studien tatsächlich
das auch mehr sex ohne kondom
stattfindet in dem nordischen modell
dass frauen mehr sex mehr sexuell
übertragbaren krankheiten ausgesetzt
werden ich finde es und ich finde es
unerträglich dass diese ganzen negativen
seiten die wissenschaftlich bewiesen
sind übrigens dass es keine meinung dass
es fakt diese einfach verschwiegen
werden und das wird das verwöhnte dieses
thema und wir versuchen ja irgendwie so
eine untere einfache lösung als
allheilmittel zu präsentieren und sagen
wir verbieten das jetzt und was nicht
sein darf kann auch nicht sein das ist
es aber nicht prostitution findet
weiterhin statt menschenhandel ist
sowieso schon verboten und menschen
fahren also menschen die mit menschen
handeln wir sind auch heute schon
kriminelle was interessiert sie das wenn
der freiherr sich auch kriminalisiert
dadurch das geht dem markt wecken riecht
nach schlafe ich die fehlende nachfrage
bricht der markt back nine werden nicht
der markt wird nur unsichtbar war die
linke in der freier die frau findet
findet der polizist die frau waren
schweden gibt es und es ist explizit
teil dieses modells intensive beratungen
in zwar ausstiegs beratungen und es wird
geld vom staat in die hand genommen und
in schweden haben sie im
verhältnis deutlich weniger prostitution
bestimmt die prostitution in schweden
ist nicht abgeschafft so wie auch bei
uns diebstahl nicht abgeschafft ist oder
mord ist nicht abgeschafft es ist aber
verboten und wenn du erwischt wirst
wirst du bestraft die haben eine andere
haltung zum thema und diese haltung
würde ich mir bei uns auch wünschen wir
sollten daran arbeiten dass frauen die
kein deutsch sprechen können dass sie
erst mal deutsch lernen und nicht direkt
prostituierte werden dass es eine
regelung gibt dass du der deutschen
sprache mächtig sein musst um sexuelle
dienstleistungen überhaupt auszuüben und
es muss klare regelungen für sex und
sexuelle dienstleistungen geben
auch fortbildungen dass man etwas lernt
was meine rechte
damit man auch sich verteidigen kann und
auch für sich einstehen kann wenn man
aber natürlich kein deutsch kann ja
nicht für sich ein stehen kann und
einfach das unwissen hat nichts darüber
weiß denn das muss geregelt werden ich
selber aber auch unwissend es gab keine
hilfestellung ich wollte diesen beruf
machen aber ich konnte nirgends hingehen
ja wenn wir da aber anpacken und da
schauen die probleme zu lösen
dann kann es vorangehen und das denken
auch verändert werden dann so sie möchte
ich gerne fragen du bist hobby domina
und du hast auch viele freundinnen die
auch selbst sechs arbeitende sind was
sagst du denn brauchen wir einen sex
kaufverbot um das bild der frau in
unserer gesellschaft zu verändern
nein ich glaube dass dabei der völlig
falschen sache angesetzt wird also um
sexismus zu beseitigen braucht es
bestimmt ganz viele andere dinge aber
dass auf dem rücken der prostituierten
auszutragen
die oft ja schon die ärmsten frauen der
armen frauen sind denen auch noch die
arbeit wegzunehmen halte ich für absolut
falsch und der anti feministische auch
du lebst ja auch dieses ganze hobby
domina ding und hau von li fen hass und
account mit dem wir auch geld verdient
ich habe auch freundinnen die
prostituierte freundinnen das aber vor
allem das was dich quasi selbst betrifft
das zeigt ja auch auf instagram und du
gibst dazu interviews und und leute mit
bei den shootings für die fans was es
denn an deiner offenheit mit dem thema
sexualität zum beispiel und auch mit
deinem eigenen körper was ist daran
wichtig für dich auch als am parlament
und auch aus der feministischen
perspektive ich finde es super import
des w
stört mich auch diese tonalität die
ganze zeit dass etwas schlimmes ist eine
prostituierte zu sein oder was schlimmes
ist eine sexuelle rinnen zu sein dass es
etwas schamhaft es ist wenn ein mann
stacks kauft weil wenn also ein mensch
wie ich erstmal wirklich da rein steckt
ist sexualität und seine eigene
körperlichkeit und all diese dinge etwas
unfassbares und ich möchte mir nicht von
irgendeiner frau die irgend so ein
captain saver hausen rom hat irgendwie
mir vorschreiben lassen dass ich ja nur
ein armes gebrochenes mädchen bin dass
es ja irgendwie nicht besser weiß und
man muss mir ja ganz ganz dringend
helfen weil das kann ja unmöglich
freiwillig sein was ich tue
dass es gewalt ist wenn ich es gegen
geld zu also ich finde es unfassbar
bevormunden und auch insofern anti
feministische ist dass die frau schon
wieder in die opferrolle gedrängt wird
ja wir sind ja alle total unmündig und
wissen nicht was wir tun mit unserem
körper
was denkt ihr dazu geht er einen schritt
auf sie zu nee ich würde gern was dazu
sagen also erst mal was gesagt man würde
den ärmsten der armen ihre arbeit
wegnehmen
das ist quatsch man gibt den ärmsten der
armen die möglichkeit eine
aufstiegshilfe zu bekommen aber
ausstiegshilfen du kannst doch für
ausstiegshilfen sein und die können ja
auch mit steuergeldern gefördert werde
aber die hinter den essen gibt es dafür
sei das andere nicht aus diese logik die
verstehe ich finde trotzdem dein recht
deinen job so zu machen wie du ihn
machst mit spaß und allem das ist so
dieses recht des tu dir nimmst
rechtfertigt nicht das leid der vielen
vielen an der ferse nicht perversen
argument jetzt sind die noten des selbst
schuld wenn es anderen noten schlecht
nein über hause ich erwerbs überhaupt
nicht aber ihr kämpft in eurer kleinen
babbel in eurer privilegierten babbel
für mehr rechte
more power trio aber was ist mit der
überwiegenden mehrheit denen es schlecht
geht wo es die solidarität zu dem was
gar nicht adressiert wird sind zum
beispiel die ungleichheiten einzige
frage beantworten anstatt einfach was
anderes zu sagen wo ist die solidarität
zu den anderen frauen
ich bin sowieso lidar inwiefern
gerade nicht ich verstehe die frage auch
er schließt du denn dass die solidarität
fehlt wenn sie für sich für sich selbst
einsetzen für den privilegierten teil
der das freiwillig war noch träume immer
du hast doch gerade eben die sind nicht
so privilegiert da ich uns die sagen
auch alle das schwedische modell ist und
ich verstehe auch nicht warum wir nicht
nach einem land wie neuseeland gucken
wir wissen ja alle dass legalisierung
und entkriminalisierung das ist nicht
die gleiche sache und neuseeland ist das
einzige land das an seinen gesetzen
gearbeitet hat mit dem new zealand
prostitution active die wirklich sex
yorkerin aus ein verschiedenen bereichen
befragt haben wie man die gesetzeslage
gestalten kann so dass diese frauen
ihren job in einem wesentlich sicheren
umfeld ausführen können und alle zahlen
sprechen dafür dass neuseenland das
einzige land ist dass den dreh raus hat
also ich möchte gerne noch mal über die
frauen reden dieses selbstbestimmt
machen deswegen was glaubst du warum
haben wir denn in unserer gesellschaft
überhaupt so ein großes problem zu
akzeptieren dass sexarbeit auch arbeit
sein kann also warum es diese debatte so
emotional aufgeladen und warum haben wir
so ein großes problem damit
ich denke weil wir alle im patriarchat
groß geworden sind dass sowohl männer
als auch frauen patriarchalisch
sozialisiert wurden
dazu gehört nicht nur dass männer frauen
/ aim sondern auch frauen frauen / eh
und ich denke dass egal wie frey wir uns
hier selbst sehen in deutschland und wie
sehr wir denken dass die frauen hier
gleichgestellt sind
dass die idee von einer selbstbestimmten
[ __ ] einfach noch immer absolut empörend
ist wieder für den großteil der
gesellschaft und alles was ich dabei
höre ist eine weitere tabuisierung der
sexualität der frau also selbst wenn man
sex käufer kriminalisiert was ist am
ende was am ende die aufgabe dessen ist
es der gesellschaft zu sagen ja sex zu
kaufen ist etwas moralisch
minderwertiges und daran gekoppelt
bedeutet ja automatisch dass eine frau
die sex verkauft auch moralisch
minderwertig ist 20 jahre lang haben wir
dieses system das wir jetzt hier haben
gefestigt so 20 jahre langen wir dieses
system gefestigt und ich bin nicht
bereit weiter in der festigung
mitzuarbeiten
wer immer erzählen dass ist so
wahnsinnig viele frauen gibt die es
gerne und selbstbestimmt machen in der
fleischindustrie ist auch niemand wir
müssen nichts verändert weil die machen
das ja alles selbst aber es hat
niemanden fleischkauf verbot geregelt
habe da immer vielleicht wir reden
vielleicht trotzdem darüber dass wir
vielleicht zu viel fleisch konsumieren
und deshalb diese fleischfabriken da gar
nicht mehr brauchen darüber reden ja
niemand niemand hat gesagt es sollen
kompletten shutdown der fleischindustrie
wieder dabei ist weil es da aus ihrer
heimat trotzdem was und in der
prostitution will niemand etwas ändern
auch sie nicht oder wäre sicher schön
dich gerne franken vergleich auch zur
konsensrunde kommen
ich find das klingt also ich kann diesen
gedanken der selbstermächtigung im
rahmen meiner möglichkeiten
nachvollziehen aber ich finde am ende
ist das irgendwie eine mogelpackung man
wir wissen alle wir leben in einem
patriarchat wir haben der
rahmenbedingungen und man justiz
vielleicht ein bisschen und sagte okay
ich werde halt immer zum objekt gemacht
von männern also mache ich selber und
verdient noch geld damit
aber das als feminismus zu verkaufen
wäre feminismus nicht dass wir sagen wir
kämpfen gemeinsam dafür dass wir nicht
mehr objektiviert werden permanent da
stunden zu warum mache ich das genauso
sehe ein mensch ist kein objekt kein
produkt ein mensch ist ein mensch und
das müssen verändern
das kann man aber auch verändern mit
sexuelle dienstleistung weil da weiß man
dass ein mensch ein mensch ist
denn der atmet und man ist dem menschen
nach jetzt mal abgesehen also sagen wir
mal wir sprechen nicht über das
nordische modell als lösung weil wir
können hier ja auch ein bisschen
rumspinnen trotzdem würde mich
interessieren wenn das nicht die art
wäre wie wir es umsetzen würden erkennst
du trotzdem an dass wir uns um
zwangsprostitution als problem kümmern
müssen erst mal grundsätzlich wir müssen
uns unbedingt mit des zwangs situation
auseinandersetzen und wir müssen
unbedingt maßnahmen entwickeln so dass
es nicht stattfindet und wenn er
stattfindet dass wir das dann dass wir
das auch weiterhin eben aufdecken können
mit dem punkt würde ich gerne bleiben
stehe hier dazu weil das ist eine sache
in der seit ihr euch alle eigentlich
einig ich bin doch gerade vorgekommen
duschen und hierbei das geht erst mal
grundsätzlich darum
wir alle das als oder dass ihr alle das
als problem an akan natürlich dann
kannst du gerne einen schritt aus fühle
ich frage mich was ist die lösung dafür
lieber lösung kann werth sprechen ich
habe drei lösungen für euch dabei ich
bin nicht ganz sicher ob wir euch
einigen werdet aber ich versuche es
einfach mal
wir kommen zur konsensrunde hälfte frage
von 13 fragen sind wir uns einig dass
wir mit staatlich finanzierten
ausstiegsprogramm für menschen mit und
ohne deutschen pass gegen zwangs und
armut prostitution vorgehen müssen
solche frage von 13 fragen kunden und
kundinnen von sexarbeit enden müssen
eine bescheinigung mit sich tragen die
sowohl eine regelmäßige
gesundheitskontrolle als auch den besuch
von informations- und aufklärungsbedarf
mend irrt es gibt so eine art freier
führerschein oder so und quasi sicher zu
gehen dass man zumindest in einem
kleinen bereich die freier kontrollieren
kann
du wirst einen kleinen schritt nach vorn
gegangen ihr beide seid nach hinten
gegangen warum das würde mich
interessieren
klein männer werden eher auf den
strassenstrich gehen und irgendwohin
wieder in die dunkelheit gehen wo sie
niemandem rechenschaft schuldig sind wo
sie keinen namen abgeben müssen und wo
sie auch ultimativ am ende sollten sie
der prostituierten gegenüber gewalttätig
seien nicht auffindbar sind von der
polizei
also wie will man bei der polizei ein
phantom anzeigen das ist ja auch ein
outings situation tatsächlich naja wer
will das bad bank mit den daten komme
ich zur dreizehnten frage von 13 fragen
sind wir uns einig dass sex arbeitende
verpflichtend an der ausarbeitung neuer
gesetze zur prostitution eingebunden
werden müssen
ok krass ich habe noch nie bei einer 13
tragen folge nur eine person hier ins
kompromiss feld holen können das ist
grundsätzlich natürlich schade zeigt
aber auch dass wir noch viel viel viel
viel mehr über dieses thema sprechen
müssen
danke euch für diese hitzige diskussion
und für eure zeit ich fand die
diskussion sehr spannend aber auch ein
bisschen zu erwarten muss ich leider
sagen also ist es leider so dass es so
zwei verschiedene positionen bei dem
thema gibt und wir uns nicht wirklich
sozusagen einig werden und auch gar
nicht meiner meinung nach einig werden
können weil entweder sieht man
prostitution niemals gewalt so wie ich
es tue
oder halt nicht na ja mir ist es wichtig
noch einmal klar zu machen es geht mir
in keiner stelle um moral
es geht mir um menschenrechte und ich
habe eben das tiefe gefühl dass die
menschenrechte der frauen sehr verletzt
werden die frauen werden verletzt ein
leib und seele und ganz ganz viele
frauen haben viele schäden
die tragen diesen rucksack ihr leben
lang mit das finde ich schwierig ja ich
denke da sind sich beide seiten von
anfang an darüber einig gewesen dass
natürlich zwangsprostitution und
menschenhandel natürlich etwas schlimmes
sind auf dieser grundlage gibt es schon
gesetze und nur weil man für die
entkriminalisierung von sex work ist
heißt es nicht dass man gesetze gegen
menschenhandel und vergewaltigung und
all diese dinge abschaffen möchte
natürlich sollen die weiter existieren
und wenn überhaupt dann von der politik
noch stärker durchgesetzt werden
wir müssen menschen mit mehr rechten
ausstatten
das heißt wir müssen natürlich auch auf
der rechtlichen ebene bestimmte räume
bestimmte handlungsräume ermöglichen
anstatt diese anstatt rechtsverletzungen
mit verboten unsichtbar zu machen und
frauen gewalt und willkür auszuliefern
ich habe das gefühl da da werden so zwei
fronten einfach aufgestellt die es aber
vielleicht auch nur in den köpfen geht
war am ende wollen wir alle das selbe
wie wollen dass es frauen besser geht
wir wollen patriarchale machtstrukturen
durchbrechen
polizisten haben hat eine lösungsansatz
aber auf der anderen seite sehe ich
nicht so richtig ein lösungsansatz wie
meine gesellschaft langfristig verändern
möchte ich wünsche mir für dieses thema
in der zukunft von beiden parteien eine
begegnung auf augenhöhe dass man
wirklich über dieses thema sprechen kann
und eine für alle parteien eine lösung
finden kann und ganz klar auch sich mit
sex wirken oder frauen die wirklichen
diese situation drinnen sind dass man
die beiseite nimmt und zusammen mit
denen weg findet ich fand das war heute
eine sehr spannende 13 fragen folgen
falls euch die folge grundsätzlich
gefallen hat dann
empfehle ich euch sehr diesen kanal hier
zu abonnieren und hier oben könnt ihr
ein weiteres video von 13 fragen
angucken
hier unten findet ihr ein weiteres video
zum thema